Wie bitte was jetzt los ok erst mal tatsächlich ich werde teil einer mars-mission ich habe sogar schon das ticket allerdings
Steige ich jetzt nicht
Im nächsten raum schrift zum mars noch ist das ja nicht möglich und wenn es möglich wird dann frühestens mit der ersten mars mission von
spacex
2024 ja das wäre dann doch noch ein bisschen hin aber was ist nun fakt und wie könnt ihr
Auch ein ticket zum mars lösen und teil einer mars-mission werden jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja was ist da los
Das hier ist tatsächlich ein ticket zum mars und zwar um teil der nächsten mars mission zu werden startet am 5 mai
2018 also schon nächstes jahr und die landung auf dem roten planeten dann schon am 26 november
2018 gestartet wird von der vandenberg lounge zeit in kalifonien es geht
Um die mars mission
Des insight lenders der sich zum ersten mal mit einem vom deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt gebauten
schlagbohrer bis zu fünf meter in den marsboden bohren wird dieser maulwurf ist teil des hp 3
experiments an bord dieses sieht flow and physical properties package soll den wärmefluss
Des maß messen und damit rückschlüsse auf die entwicklung des mars ermöglichen professor tilman spohn dazu
Im prinzip sind dies zwar einfache messungen aber in der ausführung sind sie
Kompliziert ja so der leiter dieses experiments der maulwurf des dlr wird
temperatursensoren
zentimeter für zentimeter
In den mars boden bringen getestet wurde dies unter anderem am dlr institut für raumfahrtsysteme in einer meter hohen mit sand gefüllten
röhrenradio meter
am instrument überwacht
Zudem die temperatur der oberfläche am landeplatz aus beiden
Datensätzen der messungen an der oberfläche und im inneren können die wissenschaftler dann auf den wärmefluss des planeten schließen zitat aus diesen erkenntnissen
Lernen wir dann auch mehr über die entwicklung unserer erde so der professor
spuren eigentlich sollte die mission schon
Im märz 2016 starten doch ein vakuum lag am ersten hauptacts prim and dem seismometer
Stoppte den start dieser schaden ist jetzt behoben so dass die mission jetzt starten kann mit dem
seismometer sollen bei der mission mars beben und asteroiden einschläge gemessen werden und so auf die
zusammensetzung des mars zurück geschlossen werden die mission soll endlich aufschluss darüber geben ob der kern des mars
Fest oder flüssig und damit auch ob er heiß oder eher kalt ist das sensationelle der mission ist dass die passagiere mitnehmen kann
Natürlich nicht als astronautin oder astronauten trotzdem kann man ein solches ticket
Lösen und das geht ganz einfach man geht auf die seite der nasa den link dazu
habe ich in die video beschreibung gepackt und dort trägt man ein paar daten
natürlich den eigenen namen ein und schon bekommt, man
Dieses ticket des rätsels lösung an bord des länder sind mikrochips auf denen die namen der passagiere
Gespeichert sind ist der insight länder also auf dem mars gelandet gehört, man
also
zu den ersten menschen
Deren namen auf dem mars gelandet ist schreibt mir doch mal in die kommentare ob wir es gemacht haben würde mich mal interessieren
Wie viele von euch dann zum mars fliegen hierbei klicks um ihr vater natürlich
Alles über diese mission wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen weiteren themen
Verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke ja hier geht es weiter, mit. Ihnen musk mars missionen staaten
2022 das ist wirklich sensationell also nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann